[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom flight where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today
we're talking about resiliency
so this is kind of a big topic for our
current times right when we're
struggling with all of these new
problems and sometimes problems created
by other people's Solutions as well
so what what is resiliency it's it's
kind of a buzzword there's a lot of
people who think that we we just either
have it or don't have it today we're
going to talk about what it is and some
concepts of it what philosophy has to
contribute I mean Dan what would you say
resiliency is if you had to like put it
in just a bullet point one not even a
sentence
uh positive adaptation despite adversity
okay yeah that's that's that's good so
the ability to snap back you know one
you know the vicissitudes of Life hand
you uh you know what lemons you know
making lemonade out of lemons right
lemons or grenades or razor blades or
relatives that you have to deal with or
you know uh bullies or anything that we
might encounter even you know forces of
the weather uh we can talk about
resiliency so so it's one of these
Concepts it's a it's a kind of new word
though right it's not something that
Plato and Aristotle and the stoics
talked about as such I think it's become
part of our literature in maybe the last
30 40 years right
a lot of Research into it and there's
some meta studies and you know some
pop psychology you know look at you know
anti-fragile by Talib or
um
oh what was their grit Angela duck worth
and whatnot these are all people that
have been talking about this recently
why do you think there's such a
fascination with resiliency and Concepts
that are connected with it like grit or
anti-fragility or perseverance or any
any of these other it's like a cluster
of Concepts right why why are people so
so into this even before the crisis that
we're in
well this is the
the original
generating place for it but like
definitely I see it as a response to
some of the people that feel that people
are being too
um
I guess fragile or or unable to deal
with uh stuff and they just they want
people to tiptoe around them and so you
know because there is a subset that
worry about that it tends to get other
people thinking about it and saying like
why do they think this is true and is it
true maybe we should investigate it
yeah you know this is
um a bit off topic especially this early
in the conversation but it reminds me of
something that uh was was noted uh that
you know as we've moved from an earlier
form of culture which was which was uh
more more stress was placed on
self-reliance and codes of honor and and
you know things along those lines and
we've moved there's various diagnoses of
this
um if you look at like the the lonely
crowd back in I think that was the 1960s
it was written by riesman uh talking
about moving from being sort of a
self-directed person to being an other
directed person or if you look at
discussions of moving from from an Honor
Society to a society
of yeah I'll use these sort of terms
policing and complaint
um you know where if if things go wrong
we don't take things into our own hands
we go find the authority figure to
straighten it out maybe there's maybe
there's a
a reaction against that
saying that we we want people to have
resiliency and
um that if people do then in some
respect they plus they Place less
burdens on all the rest of us maybe
that's explanations for it
it comes down a little bit to the you
know the the golden
uh mean here of like finding uh a good
place in the middle because they're
definitely really negatives to a strong
honor culture oh yeah yeah
um you know many like African Middle
Eastern cultures that happen to have
honor killings and that that seem that
is really strongly linked with uh honor
because like someone's honor that
extends even to their family and so in
order to regain your honor you must
remove that thing which caused dishonor
yeah
and and then if you go to
to the extreme other than no one's
taking any direct responsibility for
um dealing to resolve any of their
issues and so there's definitely
a golden mean I think that like the the
in between where it's kind of a good
balance there so resiliency and
responsibility are not disconnected
Concepts they're in some way
straying into each other you might say
yeah you you have responsibility over
the things that you can control I guess
okay
so yeah that that that makes a lot of
sense
um so you know
I think a lot of people talk about
resiliency is if it's a a trait that a
person either possesses or doesn't
possess that like some people are born
with it and other people just don't have
it and well too bad for them
um and then there's other people who
look at it as something that you could
have like a recipe for producing maybe
we want to say it's neither of those
either right we we want to say that that
it's maybe in between that we work off
of the temperaments that we we have and
we can improve upon them but it's I mean
I don't think that there's a blueprint
for becoming resilient that would work
for every single person in every single
case I mean what do you think about that
um
like yes and no you know there's always
going to be outliers there's bell curves
everywhere and so especially when we're
talking about human psychology but there
are definitely certain things at least
from the
um research that uh Angela Duckworth has
presented in her book grit about those
factors that lead to people having grit
and a lot of that consists with
especially when they grow up what is
their environment is their environment
conducive to learning that you do have
some sort of agency over the world that
you live in and you have and your own
abilities within that world and are you
given
um challenges that you can succeed at
and encouragement in order to do that
and a lot of her research goes to say
that like this is
um
very much a learned skill it's malleable
right it's something you can build upon
yeah you know and so before we get into
talking about different
um conceptions of of resiliency and and
related Concepts maybe we should spend a
little bit of time talking about so you
know this is a a show where we're
applying philosophy to life problems
um why why is resiliency something
particularly important or needed or or
good
um I would say one reason is well if we
want to be happy people and I don't mean
happy like you know Happy Shiny People
you know great corporate drones or
anything like that but actually you know
happy in the full sense of being
fulfilled in your life and having good
relationships and you know some like you
mentioned agency over the things that
are going to happen to you and and being
able to you know measure up to to the
the challenges that that you face and
stick to your the values that you have
so if we're going to be happy in that
sense I don't see how we can do it
without being at least to some degree
resilient because if we lack resiliency
we're going to collapse when we need it
it seems to me like it's closely
connected to earlier concepts of the the
virtue of of courage or fortitude you
know being able to persevere and and uh
go through things which which we have to
despite adversity yeah exactly it you
know Thomas Aquinas talks about
um that part of the the human
personality or Soul as being oriented
towards the difficult good so resiliency
is what we need not when things are
going great right and then everything's
we just sort of move along and keep
doing what we're doing but when we start
running into obstacles when people start
you know undermining us or calling us
names or the physical objects that we're
using unravel and break down and we need
them to work you know I I had a date
this is a total digression but I had I
had one of those days I'm I'm a little
bit under the weather right now and I
was having one of those uh you know I
have to take the dog out and kind of put
a mask on and coat and in the morning I
it was it was almost like something out
of a pink panther movie with Inspector
Clouseau where everything is like
falling apart around him so I you know I
put the mask on and and I get that on
and immediately my glasses start fogging
up and I'm I get my coat out of the
closet and the hanger you know falls
down and I have to bend down to pick it
up and then I like Bonk my head and it's
like one thing after another right and I
think you know no I'm not saying that I
was practicing great resiliency or
anything in a case like that but you
know if you if you have things like that
going on then you do need resiliency
because without it you're going to just
you know eventually just give up you're
going to say ah it's time to go back to
bed and then what happens to the dog you
know the dog is not going to be okay
with with that
um she needs to be walked and things
have to be done so it's a resiliency in
some respect it helps us to be happy but
it also helps us I guess this is another
aspect of it to be able to fulfill the
the things that we need to do not just
for ourselves but also for others so
that we're not we're not simply being a
drag on others right
not only that we gain
uh fulfillments and happiness through
being pro-social in doing those things
that we feel are benefits to others
around us
that's a that's a good point do we what
about
um getting pleasure and some measure of
happiness or satisfaction from
being able to overcome obstacles
but I think that's absolutely
a valid point
that does happen like I I feel uh
pleasure every time that I you know
write a particular piece difficult piece
of code and it works especially if it
works the first time you're like yes
well that's interesting so do you do you
get more
enjoyment out of that if it works the
first time or if there's some sort of
glitch or bug that you have to track
down and fix maybe you know five
different iterations but now you've
actually got it solved you you finally
you know mastered this thing that was
resisting you which do you get more
enjoyment out I would
um there's enjoyment for both although I
would add a third here and okay you know
it's not quite a black and white because
um for those bugs that you do have to
kind of like
constantly go dig deeper and deeper
there's the ones that are that you're
just smashing your head against your
keyboard for hours and hours and you're
not getting anywhere and there's those
bugs that are like oh this is a bug I
kind of it took me a bit but I figured
this one out but that presented another
bug and that and then I I worked on that
and so the idea that there is some
forward progress that I do have a hope a
light at the end of the tunnel is very
uh helpful for on you know in making
sure that that I'm actually enjoying
myself because I look at it as like a
giant puzzle and once I have the ability
to
if I feel like I I'm making progress
It's still enjoyable if it is just you
know nothing works and I have none of my
outputs are giving me any good feedback
and all my print statements are just you
know
for not then uh it's
it's more just a relief to be done
yeah that's that there's a different
sort of thing I you know I I've had days
when I'm teaching and nothing seems to
click and I I sort of stumble through
what it is that I I might even have
notes in front of me usually I don't I
don't need notes but sometimes I'll
actually prepare uh notes and then like
I'm not able to get the students to
contribute anything and the stuff that
I'm saying seems irrelevant and you know
we finally get to the end of the class
and I'm like oh thank God that that's
over and I remember early on in my
career when that would happen I would I
would actually feel pretty bad I would
feel like oh man maybe teaching isn't
for me you know and then you know you go
back the next next day and and usually
it's going to be better than that uh and
then you have some days where it feels
like you're hitting home runs like every
single bit of conversation that you're
having and those kind of counter balance
it
um you know actually this this brings
again we have a lot to get to but this
brings up another thing do we do we need
to have
you might say experience in in
overcoming obstacles in order to have
more resiliency
you know as I've gone on further in my
career I can have a bad day and tell
myself well this is just a blip this
happens every once in a while but early
on
you know it felt like like a big tragedy
so you're talking about like imposter
syndrome right
yeah I guess it's related to that you
know and that that's something that a
lot of people go through too so imposter
syndrome for those who are listening if
you don't know what it is you might have
have actually had it you you are doing
something and you feel like you you
don't have the capacity or you you you
don't really belong you might have the
credentials but you're not you're not
the one who's up to the challenge but
you have to pretend like you are so a
lot of people enter into jobs and feel
like they they just don't belong and
sometimes that can be produced by the
expectations of others that have been
communicated to you which are often
unrealistic you know this is a big
problem for academics particularly
people who come from not just
non-academic families but first
generation college students you know
they they get a job as as an instructor
and and everybody else around them seems
so poised and coiffed and knows exactly
what they're doing and you're like
well at least I found my office uh now
what do I do
um and I think there's there's
equivalence of that in just about every
field that we can think of right I mean
what would the equivalent be for for uh
uh computer you know same thing
you you you you go through and you you
might Ace all of your things and all of
a sudden you you're thrown into industry
and now you're you know expected to be
producing code on a regular basis and
um and maybe you're not quite familiar
with you know uh scrums and uh the the
way that people actually develop because
a lot of times the way that people
actually develop is different from the
way that you're taught in school yeah
and and so there's like you don't the
same very similar idea that to what you
described in Academia you're like okay
here I I think I'm doing I'm just gonna
try to uh tread water until I understand
and then uh and then hopefully at the
end of this total I'm going to be able
to be able to you know stand up on my
own two feet but yeah I think that that
comes any big change in experience and
uh and environment
um you know
there's very little that can directly
one for one
uh prepare you for going from school to
uh to a job in the private sector or
even from jobs between different
companies that can be true yeah another
level
people have their their they they come
in and they say well that's not how they
did it in my previous company and well
too bad right because this is how we do
it here you know I see I see quite a lot
of that as somebody who teaches at
different places there are people who
have got their idea about what an
institution ought to be like
from only being in one Institution for a
very long time and then when they there
is somewhere else they're they're like
totally lost so I mean does that fit it
does that tie in with resiliency this
this theme that we have is being able to
navigate new things a matter of
resiliency in some way
well yeah you're being presented with
um adversity of trying to adapt to a new
environment and the ability to
positively adapt to that new adverse
environment without you know crumbling
okay yeah yeah that makes that makes
good sense
so I know you so you have some stuff
lined up and yeah so I've gotta go ahead
I've got a quote from um
uh it's from that potatoes and it's got
a little bit of intro from Bill Irvine
from his book The stoic challenge
um and so the Stoke philosopher uh
peconius akrip uh oh wowness
um who was in around uh 67 BCE was
openly critical of the emperor Nero a
messenger came to inform him that he was
being tried in the Senate his response I
hope it goes well but it is time for me
to exercise and bathe so that is what I
will do subsequently another messenger
appeared with the news that he had been
found guilty of treasonous behavior and
condemned to banishment or to death he
asked to banishment the messenger
replied uh a group highness responded
with a question was my estate in acrisia
Taken Noah said the messenger in that
case said agrippanyis I will go to
acrisia and dine
so how does this illustrate
um resilience
for all of us then
you know she had a negative a very
Advanced adverse situation happening
he's being tried for treason he doesn't
even get to go and uh defend himself in
front of the Senate and he takes it in
stride is like well I'm eating now
there's nothing I can do about this why
should I be you know up in arms or you
know worried about this thing
and then later on he finds out that he
has been condemned and he's like well
okay I have only so many options
available to me and either I can sit
here and gnash my teeth and and be upset
about this or I can take the best option
that's available to me at the moment and
do that because what else am I going to
do yeah so he is a stoic philosopher do
you think it makes a difference what
school he belongs to
is is there something about the stoic
school that ties in
particularly with with resilience
I mean I know what I think about that
what do you think I'd say the dichotomy
of control do you think that as well or
well that's certainly a technique that
or rather not a technique but but more
of a basic uh concept that that helps
out you know and we should we should
remind our listeners of what the
dichotomy of control is so Epictetus
tells us some things are in our control
or up to us and other things are not so
this is you know a two two-fold thing a
dichotomy and the reason he does that is
not just to be you know interested in
classification but there's a practical
purpose to it if we focus on the things
that are actually in our control then we
can indeed do do something about them we
can pay attention to how we for example
think about things or our emotional
responses or the choices that we're
going to make if we focus too much on
the things that are outside of our
control which isn't to say we should
disregard them all together but if we
focus on them as if they're the things
that count the most like our money or
possessions or our body or reputation
we're going to be miserable he says in
part because we're going to ignore the
things that we actually can do something
about like our our reactions to things
right
right and so in this regard he has the
the ability to affect what his choices
are going forward and so
um and he could decide to like
go and and try to somehow reverse his
decision but he probably knows that that
is a Fool's error and he's just a
philosopher he's not a doesn't have much
political power and so he's like well
you know just take the the path that
results in the best experience for me at
the time yeah I mean Nero would have
been a particularly difficult person to
to convince of anything rational right
but even even if you were dealing with
let's say he was he had to go over to
convince Marcus Aurelius not to mess
around with him it was just all a
misunderstanding it could still remain a
misunderstanding right that's not in our
control and Epictetus says any time that
you place your desire your aversion in
things that another person controls like
whether you're condemned or not or
whether you get a fair trial you you are
in essence making yourself a slave of
that person you are making yourself
subject to whatever it is that they they
want to do so if we're looking at things
from a stoic perspective is that
something that we should avoid in order
to become more resilient
um relying on relying on
um other people to do things
the way that we want them to be done or
not to do things that we're averse to
being done
I think that is you know Paramount and
you know if you are
requiring other people to either make
you happy or to you know
um
yeah I guess that's the really the main
thing because there's lots of things
that we might like but like for
our own Peace of Mind our own uh
mindfulness I guess to allow someone to
uh their actions and their thoughts and
their words to uh make us
go into negative emotions is is how a
friend of mine used to say on letting
them live rent free within your head
yeah
yeah you know another another sort of uh
proverb that I found particularly
helpful for these sorts of things is
saying not my circus not my monkeys you
know when when there's like things going
on because I'm the kind of person and I
and so are other people in my family who
like to get into the the business and
make things better at least what we
think is better and then we we allow
ourselves to feel as if we're
responsible for things that we're not
actually responsible for they're not
they're not up to us and so learning to
actually dissociate from things and and
not to say oh I just don't care at all
but just to say not my circus not my
monkeys it's somebody else's thing to do
you know
um there's another catchphrase too as
well not co-signing other people's BS
right uh you know because when when you
tie in with somebody else's point of
view or project and you don't exercise a
kind of you know Reserve from it
then you know you you are
placing yourself on the line you might
say right and
um you you wind up getting committed by
them to all sorts of things that perhaps
aren't good for you and and maybe part
of being resilient then is learning how
to disentangle one's own agency from
that of others at the right time you
know
or or disentangle it from the wrong
sorts of others maybe we need to work
with some people
but other people we need to almost
insulate our actions from so that they
can't screw them up
that is a very Salient Point very you
know uh
powerful point you know we
they say that we're the average of the
five people that we're closest to uh oh
yeah yeah
um but yeah definitely
those people that are closest to you
definitely do have some sort of
influence about the what you think what
you do and you know the whole idea of
like falling in with the wrong crowd you
know can be summed up here something
else that the stoics talk quite a lot
about right the choosing our companions
wisely so you know Epictetus has that
it's it's not quite you know if you roll
around with a pig in the mud you're
going to get muddy uh the pig you know
is quite happy with that he he says it
about people if you hang out with the
wrong sort of people You're Gonna Get
You Know You're whatever they're doing
is gonna rub off on you and I think he
uses the metaphor of mud at one point
you know
um and Seneca says similar stuff too
right we the people who we routinely
engage with
we end up inevitably being influenced by
them so what if we have you know I I
came across this really great
uh phrase in a self-help book and I
don't remember what it was it was the
only thing I liked about the self-help
book but it called some people crazy
makers what if we have what if we have
crazy makers in our life like people in
our family or neighbors or friend group
or something like that
um if we how do you just want to stir
the pot or they don't know that they're
sure in the pot it could be all sorts of
things some some people really like
drama right so they they do stir the pot
other people are just kind of selfish
and oblivious to the feelings of others
and they just do what they're gonna do
and you can tell them you know I don't
like when you do that and be nice and
assertive with them but they don't care
um there's other things you know some
people have debilitating
uh issues that perhaps don't have to be
debilitating in the way that they are
for them but they allow them to be and
then somehow it's it's our our problem
our issue to deal with and so there
could be a lot of different permutations
on this but let's say we don't want to
like cut these people out of our life
should if we want to be resilient do we
need to find ways to minimize the the
effects of of what they're doing I think
we probably have to do that to some
degree so we you know maybe we'd use the
stoic technique of
dissociating the appearance from our our
judgment about that and and questioning
our judgments so if they're being
insulting maybe we don't interpret it as
an insult and we say that's that's my
part I'm the one who's reading that into
it uh really they're just behaving the
way that they do or we we remind
ourselves they're doing what they're
doing because that appears to be them to
them the best thing to do there's
there's a lot of techniques that the
stoics have so all of those I would
think would help us to
to exercise resilience and build
resilience while at the same time doing
something else that the stoics think is
really important which is maintaining
our relationships
and and fulfilling the duties that are
inherent in in as Epictetus says the
very names of the relationships like
being a son or being a
sibling or so was this your original
thought when you were talking about
agrapyness and that his he has a certain
responsibility as a I guess a Roman
citizen in this case to follow the
dictates of how the Roman political
apparatus has been set up I hadn't
thought about that but I think he
probably would go along with it sort of
like as you know Socrates accepting the
the penalty that Athens as he knew very
unfairly imposed on him I think
agropinus would probably go along with
that but there's another side to it
which is you know if you if you're going
to be sentenced and executed how are you
going to deal with it are you are you
going to like say oh this is so unfair
you know uh Nero a tyrant that's that's
actually probably less effective than
like just saying oh and you don't want
to just be like well whatever happens uh
it's a-okay with me instead you could be
like well you know
um I guess I'll go along with this but
everybody knows you know what the score
is here and and that I think that in
some ways could be
more effective although when you're
dealing with a Nero man that's
that's pretty much when you deal with
the tyrants you know what what are the
the
normal way of dealing with things get
thrown out I guess this is kind of to
the the basis of the American Revolution
that they believe that King George is
the tyrant in this they needed to sever
their political connections with them
but yeah although more of a a group
versus a group instead of an individual
versus the group yeah I mean in that
case there were all sorts of aggravating
circumstances I mean you could see this
in like the the things that they're
ticked off about like one of them that
that even got put into the Bill of
Rights was about you know you can't
board soldiers in people's houses that
seem to really ticked off a lot of
people right and it makes sense because
they're they're they're you know you're
not just like putting them up in your
room or something you got to feed these
these hungry guys too and uh so you know
they they saw that as particularly
egregious but I mean it's interesting
with the American Revolution about
one-third of the people were for it and
about one-third of the people were
against it and became Tories and about 1
third of the people just didn't care one
way or the other and a lot a lot of
times what gets done is not because like
the totality of the people turn against
something it's because some motivated
individuals are able to you know make
the case keep making the case and then
in the case of the American Revolution
do do all sorts of actions like storing
up weapons and
um you know gunpowder and and you know
appointing officers and you know raising
militias and we could we could transpose
this out of that sort of circumstance
and think about the resiliency you know
I mean think about this so does it take
resiliency to stay inside and when you
go outside to wear a mask like the CDC
is recommending that you do I think it I
think it actually does you know I I
absolutely agree it is uh it's a very
difficult thing he's like I just want to
go outside and do all the regular things
that I do on a normal basis yeah and why
do it to have this thing on my face and
it itches and I was supposed to not
touch my face yeah all those things
require a amount of willpower for you to
overcome these things but you'll if you
look in the grand scheme of things and
like what the reasoning behind this and
there's this reasoning like I guess
pro-social definitely pro-social that
you know you're trying to improve the
health of those other people around you
um you know
move beyond your your selfish attitudes
I guess hopefully yeah and I would say
that the people who are like really
complaining about this and so bent out
of shape about it and it doesn't just
include like people protesting in these
you know liberate this and that sort of
things I mean I I wear a mask every time
I go out in part because we're not
taking any chances
um I have to walk the dog three times a
day and I remember just the other day
they were there were 320-something guys
that were walking down the street
clearly not social distancing and they
were like you know they're the sort of
of people who were
um perhaps a little bit too what would
you call it they were too public they
were they were they were putting on a
show about how you know they weren't
scared of of the coronavirus and they
saw me wearing a mask and walking the
dog and then they were talking very
loudly about how you know they don't
they don't care about us not going to
affect them and all that and I was I was
I didn't say anything but I was thinking
to myself you know the mask isn't really
just to protect you only about a quarter
of what's going on with the mask is that
you're actually like trying to keep your
own uh potentially infectious breath
from expelling all these these things
out into the the air for other people
and to like make a make a scene about it
which is what they were doing they were
they were you know in the old days uh
you know they use this word hypocrite
and it you know just means the actor
somebody who puts the mask on they were
putting a mask on but the mask was that
of like hyper confidence you know and I
see that and I'm like
well you know it it's going to take a
while to convince some of these these
people and and they didn't necessarily
have to be 20-somethings they could have
been 40 year olds they could have been
60 year olds but it's the it's the
mindset
um so it's not even just like laziness
or selfishness or something like that
um it's sometimes also a I'm gonna like
show everybody how unaffected I am and
in a way so coming back to resilience
that's like the opposite of resilience
in a way you know if we think about
resilience in terms of like you said a
mean kind of an Aristotelian fashion so
on the one side you've got the oh I
can't handle this I break down you know
oh what was me this is this is the end
you know I tried so hard but my my
efforts have failed right we have that
sort of thing on the other side we have
the people who are you know so hard so
tough but they're not really they're
they're kind of putting on a show that's
not real resiliency
and they're when they encounter genuine
difficulties they're probably going to
fold just like the other people
and so this kind of makes me think of
you know your topic that you have here
on our list is uh existentialism and
Nietzsche oh yeah the famous quote that
everybody brings up I knew we had to
talk about that right
um but before we get to the quote I was
thinking about the idea of having like
overarching stories that we are given
and so especially when you're young
you're you're
latch on to these stories of like like
this vitality and this thing isn't going
to affect me as well as you know it is a
staple of on people that are young to
who not quite totally take in the full
consequences of their actions yeah
um they tend to be uh a little bit more
selfish just because of like the lack of
lived experience and so I see this the
story that is that they are exuding
um that is not a
a real story but a story that they've
just uh glummed on to and they're all
telling each other back and forth right
to like sort of yeah like sort of like
people who have to uh get their friends
to egg them on to to do something you
know yeah
yeah so what's the quote oh well it's
it's the one that you find being used in
everything from Conan the Barbarian at
the start uh you know self-help books
what actually in pop songs too right
what doesn't kill me makes me stronger
and it's from the Twilight of the idols
and it starts out out of life's School
of War so that's even more you know uh
daring and and Marshall and okay so you
know what does that mean should we
should we like get hit by a car because
that does not kill me I'll actually come
out of that stronger probably not you
know and if you get if you get
coronavirus
um you know you may recover from it but
a lot of people are coming out of it
with lasting long and hard and and other
things damaged so I don't know that this
is actually that great of a a idea taken
straight right we probably have to
qualify it in some ways and that's yeah
that leads to the I know you wanted to
talk about the notion of anti-fragility
yeah yeah exactly and so this is the
idea that there are certain systems both
in biology and and computer science and
sociology that are
benefited by having stresses exerted
upon it and so for example how do we
build muscles we lift weights and what
is that actually doing it is actually
ripping your muscle tissue and that is
the resp that causes your body to
respond by building more and stronger
muscles in its place as well as uh
Wolf's Law which describes how bones
grow stronger due to extreme loads as
well as a lot of the in computer science
a lot of
um
uh machine learning is required is
basically especially on non-directed
machine learning has uh an agent like
for example a driverless car drive
through things and it's constantly
Gathering data and the more data it gets
the more adverse like interactions the
better it will be able to respond to
situations in the future
you know that reminds me of of something
interesting that we saw on the internet
in the last year which is
um the people who had the the robots and
they were pushing it around and knocking
it down and do you remember that oh
everyone was like well this is how you
get Skynet right this is you know you're
you're being mean to the robot it's
gonna somehow remember and then they had
to they had to go online and say we're
not actually being mean to the robot
we're actually helping it to learn how
to deal with adverse circumstances you
know like uh what what if it's on the
factory floor and something goes under
its foot or knocks it down or something
like that how is it going to deal with
that right
yes the Boston Dynamics car uh dog okay
yeah or dog robot whatever you want to
call it yeah
uh yeah so that's that's that's part of
it right
yeah on it
I don't know exactly if at that point in
time they were doing learning because
you can you can do have two processes
you have the learning process and then
you just have like the running what
you've already been learned so you think
so much but yes we're actually being
mean to the robot
I guess
is it that opens up a whole can of worms
how can you be mean to it yeah and at
what point in time does a robot have
agency or adamant
ESS
yeah
uh but that is
a far afield but yeah you know somebody
who I wasn't actually thinking about
talking about originally but now it
brings it to mind
um is the great uh
strategist of the 20th century the late
20th century Edward litvock who has this
wonderful book called strategy the logic
of War and Peace and he doesn't use the
word anti-fragile which is you know
Talib
essentially coins that but he talks
about something very similar in how
um the Investments that people make into
for example defensive systems they often
turn out to be a bad investment and they
they get beaten by all sorts of
countermeasures because the natural
thing in any sort of strategic back and
forth is is what he would he terms
dialectics and he's he's taking this you
know he's going all the way back to
Klaus Vitz who it was a great you know
uh military theorist in the early 19th
century
um but it it's very interesting because
lutvac applied this to the Soviet Union
in a book called the Grand strategy of
the Soviet Union he uh applied it to
whether aircraft carrier groups are
really a great investment like a lot of
people were thinking that they were uh
back in the I think the book was from
the 90s you know the the strategy and
um it's a similar thing that that a lot
of systems that we often take as being
fragile or as being rigid turn out to be
anti-fragile many many other people turn
out to be anti-fragile and then we are
opposed once they respond we're were
surprised and we're posed with our own
challenges in dealing with them and you
know it doesn't always have to be
antagonistic we could actually in some
cases be disabled by the responses of
people who we thought would never want
to cooperate with us and never be
reasonable suddenly being so and uh were
suddenly placed in a position where
maybe we have challenges of too many
resources or too many choices to make or
things
not presenting that constant pushback on
us and then you know what would Auntie
what would anti-fragility or or
resilience tell us about these sorts of
things so to say just um you know great
everything worked out for you take it
easy now I I don't know that that would
be the response if you're really because
then it presents you new problems you
know they're good problems but they're
definitely there's still obstacles to I
know say everyone wants to work together
but then how do you organize all the
everyone to work together and work
together well and there's still things
to progress and to uh tweak to hopefully
come to better outcomes
um even though there's not a a direct
antagonist okay yeah that makes sense
so is there more to say about
anti-fragility you think I think we're
good we might need to move down to our
question if we're going to actually make
it to that yeah yeah that's unless
there's anything that you really need
from the the main topic well I I just
wanted to mention that Margaret Graver
who wrote a wonderful book called
stoicism and emotion
also gave the plenary address at stoicon
when it was in Toronto several years ago
and she did a discussion about how the
stoics are different from the cynics and
the epicureans when it came to the
emotions and and dealing with the
emotions and The Epicure it's sort of
like Goldilocks right the epicureans in
some way are too soft and the cynics are
too hard they focused on like trying to
almost eradicate things that that would
interfere with you know virtue and
happiness and and she viewed the stoics
as having a a better position for as she
put it the heart
um you know and so I think her view on
that is it fits in really well with this
notion of anti-fragility the goal is not
to like Harden oneself up so that you'll
never have challenges you'll you know
it's not even a question of overcoming
them nor is it a matter of like
withdrawing yourself from life so that
things work out better for you the soft
Epicurean way rather it's to be able to
handle the challenges that come to you
in in your emotional responses and to be
able to shape them and remold them and
then come back at things sort of like
the wrestler getting back up after the
the fall so I think that that was the
only thing I wanted to really stress
um I guess I I want to just touch really
quick on reframing which is a yeah yeah
a way of on you know I guess we'll get
to it a little bit with our practice of
negative visualization but this is to uh
change what you think is bad and like
you know
in negative visualization you you think
about
um like the worst possible things that
could happen and then once you realize
that those things don't happen you you
realize that you're wife now is actually
a lot better than yeah uh the the what
could happen as the worst but uh yeah
lens a sense of perspective right
and um and it helps us uh learn from the
mistakes we've made
um by by reframing and uh
yeah I'm gonna move on to the question
here then so uh the question is uh go
ahead wait okay
um how to Foster resiliency in someone
who lacks it
um someone who is close to uh you know
do you is it better for you to
um help them learn resiliency or is it
better to Shield them from the the
negative and the antagonistics people of
the world
yeah this is this is a very common
problem that
um parents have for one thing but not
just parents but spouses can have that
or significant others maybe it also
affects friends
um
teachers sometimes have to deal with
this in terms of students and some some
students actually have to do a little
bit of shielding of of teachers from
time to time as well right and I think
this this applies to the workplace
um you know what do you do with your
co-worker who just can't handle
getting bad news or maybe even can't
handle being given additional deadlines
you know do you do you try how do you
you know deal with this should you try
to support them in some way and try you
know do you take up the slack that's not
actually supporting them right because
ideally you want them to be resilient
it's good for them to be resilient and
it's also not great for them to be
continually leaning on you or do you you
know do you Shield them from it and say
ah they they can't handle it or do you
cut them loose that would be another
option as well although hopefully not
exercised in too many cases
right uh I guess my first feeling is
like if you can teach them some of the
skills we talked about how uh we're on a
spectrum here and we everyone's got a a
natural proclivity to resilience or not
but is definitely something that is
malleable yeah and it pres provided the
right environment for doing that so if
you have those those friends or
co-workers if you can provide them some
situations like help build up their
um own confidence their uh
in the ability to actually be resilient
to things then it's going to make your
life and their lives better yeah
that's that's actually that that you
know and you might even like I'm not
saying like keep score or necessarily
like write things down in a journal but
maybe this is something that happens
over time right it's not like people
snap their fingers and suddenly become
more resilient it happens like like
building muscle right you work out and
it gets a little stronger and you work
out and it gets a little stronger so
instead of so for example yeah go ahead
I I in uh organization that used to be
part of um when new members joined we
would give them
positions within the organizations that
were small and minor and easy to do in
order for their as their first couple
months within the organization that they
would gain on their trust in themselves
that they are able to do these things
and you know part of it was used as a
barometer to see if they could actually
come through and so they would give be
given more responsibility but also is
like okay if you if you throw people
right into the deep end it's kind of
sink or swim but if you if you yeah I'm
doing things right yeah but
but to if you don't have the resilience
built up then that's that's just gonna
you know be a shock to their system you
need to
um get them into a challenging position
not a fearful position
you know it I I have set up classes in
such a way that students get to fail
early and fail on fairly low stakes
things so that they then can take you
know the feedback that I give them and
and sometimes it's just a matter of like
actually seeing paying attention to what
the assignment requires them to do but
sometimes there's other things going on
and so by failing in in small ways early
on they can you know come back from that
and and start to succeed in being able
to perform according to the the
standards that that we want
um and you know so some of the students
get frustrated with it they're like
you know I don't like to fail well you
know failing is going to be a big part
of your life so you know you may as well
learn how to handle it early on and it's
going to be a big part of career and
it's going to be a big part of
relationships so uh you know in a way
resiliency necessarily involves learning
how not just to fail and not screw
everything up or blow it out of
proportion but how to come back from it
right how to persevere right
I I think there's so much
pressure on a lot of people to get it
right the first time always especially
within an academic setting that any
setback and I I've experienced that in
my own life as well in the academic
setting of like getting a a paper that I
I thought deserved better and having to
go in like
go through everything line by line to
figure out like what what were you
thinking or what was I thinking why why
am I failing here me too and it's very
frustrating yeah
um but you you learn the more that you
are exposed to that failure the more you
realize that it's not a bad thing so
there's the Mantra in Silicon Valley uh
pale fast and fail often yeah and uh
because basically you actually learn
more from failure than they do from a
success you yes you know this can lead
to complacency right right
yeah uh so you know talking about like
the the last bit of your thing of
potentially dropping your friend or um
like is there a time when there are
people in your life that just do not
have any resiliency and do they
or do they no longer kind of like I
guess worthy of of your friendship
what's your opinion on that I I don't
know that it would be a I mean you could
if it's about like friendship in the
fullest sense I guess we could use words
like worthy or things like that because
we should be able to choose our friends
we we shouldn't have friendship like
thrust upon us as like a big obligation
that we we have to have right when it
comes to other kinds of relationships
you know
um maybe it's less like that you know uh
when we take marriage vows it's there's
a good reason why it's for richer and
poorer right in sickness and health and
all all that sort of stuff
um and you know I think when it comes to
familial relationships unless somebody's
being like abusive or exploitative or
something like that we probably
shouldn't cut them loose but
um that doesn't mean that they we have
to like pretend that it's wonderful to
be with them all the time
or that we wouldn't like I mean here's
there's sort of the bottom line we don't
want people just to have resilience so
they're not a pain in the rear for us we
want them to have resilience because
it's better to have it than not to have
it it's it to lack it is in some way to
live a life that becomes impoverished
because it subjects one to being pushed
around by the fear of failure or other
anxieties or one's inability to handle
one's emotional response of anger or all
sorts of other things right it's
resiliency is something that allows a
human being to exercise agency and to
feel like they're they're in control of
their little bit of the universe that
they they do control
all right I think we need to move on to
our practice which is negative
visualization and I touched on that just
a little bit
um yeah now we we discussed this a
couple episodes back so we're bringing
some new and richer things to it this
time right
um so we we build resilience by becoming
acquainted with manageable stress and
one way we can do this is through
negative visualization the idea of
sitting and thinking of negative things
that happen this is kind of the opposite
of positive thinking yeah
um uh because you know the problem with
positive thinking is you think something
great is going to happen and that
reality comes and smacks you in the face
because everything didn't turn out quite
well and so the idea here is well if you
look at it the worst things that could
happen or bad things that could happen
then you realize that most of the time
those things actually won't happen and
now your perception of what could happen
to reality is a good one
um
yeah there's there's also a reframing
aspect to it as well sometimes if we sit
and we we really look at the things that
we fear or dread or you know view is as
threatening to us if we if we think it
through there I mean there's two things
that can happen with it one is we can
realize well actually that's not that
bad you know like what what would happen
if I did get sick well you know if I get
sick I I might die from it but I might
not you know so maybe getting sick and
if you do diet then it doesn't matter
anymore
true yeah and and there's that whole
thing I mean we could go into the like
well you know if you go to heaven if you
go to hell that the the that leads to an
Irish joke eventually uh where you're
shaking hands with all your friends down
in hell right
but it's so but it sounds like it's like
a decision tree right and so I mean
there's that aspect to it so we we can
become you know we can be we have a
better perspective on it you know like
what if I'm giving a a talk and my pants
fall down ah people will laugh it might
go on YouTube but it's not going to be
the end of my career you know I might
become the Prince fall down guy
um so that that's and it's only going to
get worse if you get super embarrassed
up on stage
or you start shouting at people don't
look at my pants
three big things that I can see that are
benefits of doing the negative
visualization is one we can become
desensitized to those things that we
might have feared that might happen to
us uh two is that we are now a safe
place to Think Through what we Canon
should do in that situation because a
lot of times these situations are thrust
upon us and we're like Oh shoot what do
I do because you haven't thought it
through before right exactly so this
helps uh us from freezing up because we
already have a kind of a plan in place
the last one is to um to Anchor our
perception of reality to something worse
than the reality that we actually are
experiencing
yeah and that puts it in perspective too
right we would say it could be worse
um I think a lot of people when they
hear that they're like oh that's a
pessimist there but no no that's that's
actually somebody who's being optimistic
they're they're saying this isn't as bad
as it could get
right you know another thing too with
negative visualization from the stoic
perspective and I know we got to wrap up
really quick here it could be used with
the dichotomy of control to say listen
if these things happen to my possessions
my reputation my body
um that is not the end of the world for
me because none of these things can
actually turn me into a bad person I
think a lot of people think that if they
and it's because of our culture if
they're not successful or they go from
being successful to being you know as we
often say failures or losers that
somehow that's a moral failing on their
part when I mean we know that the
economy is not fair uh so many other
things are not fair and people lose out
because of that I think we have to wrap
up now and we end with people are
Disturbed not by things but by their
judgments about those things be well
[Music]
foreign